that fire saga shirt yes that's amazing
can I get late yeah I'm selling them
amazing I think I'll see ok let me write
that down
Hey
probably you got to keep your volcano
man costume like where is it that is a
great question no I did not get to keep
it I don't know how I would have been
able to pack it to be quite honest a lot
a lot of pieces a lot of basically a
superhero costume yeah I mess it was
something like that you just wear it on
the plane and just deal with it it is
the closest though I will get to playing
a superhero it was like I mean you and
Rachel McAdams getting to work so
closely together and you guys are great
and you gotta say some nice things
because here's the thing she was like
Canada's sweetheart
yeah and it's I think it's actually an
offense to not say something nice about
her it's gonna be hard cuz you know
she's a handful yeah no you know I she's
like so impressive with how she's just
able to kind of go and you know play a
comedic character at the same time in
the middle of of a movie that's openly
silly and really trying to make you
laugh she can just bring herself to
tears and find this emotion I mean she
just she shows off just both what a
great actress she is and and we we had
the best time getting to know each other
and hanging out and I would say her her
best comedic performance since Mean
Girls I'm gonna put it out there right
on yeah yeah definitely but if you were
to um have anyone by your side any
singer that you guys were to enter the
year
Song Contest you needed a singer to sing
we get a rent who would it be any singer
Oh probably well I think would be
hilarious to be standing next to Neil
Diamond I would take Neil Diamond out
there yeah I think he's got yeah I think
he's got the Eurovision magic especially
if you're in both addresses volcano man
ad pay up yeah or anything what's that
or in anything he used to wear from the
70s did you pick up any Icelandic words
that you can now use you know in your
daily life over the course this no I've
got a ton of Swedish I know a lot of
Swedish words but no I did not I did not
pick up any Icelandic I mean we were
only there for four four days I know
that's no excuse I should have should
have retained more sweet Icelandic
vocabulary but I I didn't I'm sorry okay
well finally finally between you and Dan
and Rachel who is actually winning in
the same competition Oh in terms of
performing hmm definitely Lars yeah no
there's no yeah Lars Lars only thinks
about performing
yeah he's obsessed with with his hair
with costumes staging all of it he's as
a singular focus so I think Lars at
least in his own mind would win even
though Dan Steve left off is a very very
powerful performer Lars is a lot of you
know admiration for him yeah I like I
like the confidence though well Lars
Lars takes it I'm gonna take a report
yeah
whether it's earned or not he's
confident awesome
well they did so much for the time I'll
expect those shirts in the milk okay
it's alright girls